Speaker 1: Welcome everybody. Few things I wanted
to get to this week, I didn't have the chance
and now I do. So let's do it. There is a quaint
little hypothesis from MyPillow CEO and founder
Mike Lindell about the forthcoming election, and
as many of you know, Mike Pillow as we know him,
or even just pillow for short, he is determined
to grind to us to a screeching halt. The 2022 and
2024 elections and his new idea is something about
voting machines, and he's explaining it to Steve
Bannon. And it's the blind leading the blind.
And I can't tell whether Bannon believed this,
this stuff or whether either of them do. But
take a look at the new strategy. This is wild
Speaker 2: live. Link up with these tech
technology people that you can actually go and
get it to individual states and get injunctions
to basically shut down the machines to be used in
the 2020 midterm elections and state elections.
Yup. Yeah. Twenty twenty two. That's correct,
Steve. In any elections, it would be over. We're
going to get it is over. I mean, to injunctions.
And it's with no machines because
they cannot do elections accurately
and they can and they can be manipulated.
Speaker 1: It wouldn't be accurate under percent.
Speaker 2: They say, no, they did it their court.
Now they're guilty. It's in violation of our
fundamental rights to vote under 40 to Dash
U.S.C. one nine eight three a violation of
equal protection, also due process. We are
starting with seven states. Immediately we're
going. We're going. We're going to get to every
state and every. Of course, you're going to get
pushback and stuff. But every state, the
people, by the way, you know who the stand,
who has the standing. All the voter. Steve Yeah.
Speaker 1: So this there's a funny aspect to this
and pillow is obsessed with machines,
and he's trying to remember when he
said he was going to sue every machine.
Speaker 2: We're doing a class-action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Our daughter is one of
the funniest class. My espresso machine has
gone into hiding because of this forthcoming
lawsuit. It is absolutely horrified. It may
be completely shut down. The funny thing about
this is it's cartoonish. It's it's off the wall.
It's kooky, it's all of these different things.
But the precedent that or the rules, the law
that pillow cites just doesn't have anything
to do with the use of voting machines. When he
talks about 42 U.S. Code 1983, that's a section
called Civil Action for Deprivation of Rights.
And when you read it, it says every person
and anyone who is deprived of a right has the
ability to seek recourses and, you know, gives you
standing over the fact that voting machines are
used doesn't deprive anyone of rights. You would
have to demonstrate that. And of course, pillow
and others have failed to demonstrate that the
mere existence of voting machines deprives someone
of the right to vote, which is the right that
we're talking about here. In addition to this,
there's kind of the other side of it, which is
if you got rid of all machines, if you if you did
that and we simply had a universal vote by mail,
everybody mails in a paper ballot and it's paper
ballots counted one by one and then recounted, You
count them and then you recount them. OK, I would
be fine with that, and it wouldn't be particularly
good for Republicans. They love to claim, oh, the
left would would use Mail-In Ballots for fraud and
all of it. There's there's no evidence of that.
And we saw that in 2020 they claimed it, but there
was not actually any evidence of it. It would take
a really long time and we've gotten used to what
we want results sooner than that. But I would
be fine with universal vote by mail and count
every ballot by hand and have a paper trail.
I'm OK with that, and I think many on the left
would be the reason they are trying to mess with
the machines, so to speak, is both self-serving
and due to things they misunderstand, as is often
the case with much of what Republicans do. So does
Pillow believe this, that he's about to shut down
all these elections because they're getting rid
of all the machines? There's Steve Bannon. It's
hard to believe that anyone would believe it.
At the same time, they've been saying it for a
year and a half. So I don't know you be the judge.